[Music]
now since it is Christmas we thought we
would give our viewers what they want
and we know what they want because they
put it in the comments a lot and that
what they want is more Rod little
so as a Christmas tree here he is our
health and wellness correspondent Rod
little uh who has a typically brilliant
column uh in our Christmas edition about
wokery
um Rod I thought I'd start by saying
because we have a bit of a um debate in
the office about whether to use the word
woke
um because on one hand it seems to have
degenerated into a meaningless term of
abuse
um and on the other it's a very useful
catch-all uh for a lot of the things
that are most awful about the world uh
you clearly have decided you will use it
but do you know what I mean when I say
that it's different I know exactly what
you mean it's an awful word and it
doesn't quite uh Express what we mean
when we say it uh Progressive politics
is one way around it identitarian
politics is another way around it though
that doesn't quite get you into the uh
the decolonization stuff quite so easily
and the thrashing of the nation's
history I mean the reason I use it and
you used it in this particular uh pieces
is that everyone understands it yeah
everyone knows what I mean uh there are
other words wank for example is one such
and I did once use that but
um
any four letter word beginning with w
indeed
well as you say in the column it is not
uh cultural Marxism is it even though a
lot of people particularly right Wingers
like to say that it is
something to do with cultural Marxism as
I say in the column you know Marx was I
don't have a huge amount of love for
Karl Marx but you could not argue with
being anything other than both an
empiricist
and
a communitarian I mean those two things
uh but he is rather famously both of
those two things whereas whereas World
Korean identity politics is kind of
post-rational and uh has no time for
empiricism whatsoever and it's of course
by definition individualistic
I suppose what people are getting at
there is that they think it's a sort of
uh it's on it's on a mission to March
through the institutions and Destroy
them all
yeah yeah it's it's the old gramsky's
saying sure but they also mean that it's
left-wing you know it's a bit like
anyone who's accused of being right wing
eventually the the uh the comparison
stretches back to Hitler so it is with
with anything on the left uh if you wish
to denigrate it you say it's Marxist
um uh and that so that's about as far as
it goes I mean there is some truth
that the Frankfurt School hawkenheimer
uh particularly
um habermas Marcus
there's something in there which feeds
in without question to what we call
wokism
um largely a sense of a disdain of
Bourgeois moral values
um and a dislike of any form of
authority and this in injunction that
one had to express oneself Christ
there's anything done us more damage
than that expressing oneself so so there
is a little bit of that in there but I
also think by the same token there's a
little bit of the of the Frankfurt of
the of The Chicago School of economics
in there which was also very very
individualistic and uh did away with the
notion of society but didn't really
agree with Society or thought it was
something that one should stay away from
for tour possible and was it was about
you know but that was largely about
money but nonetheless it was very very
individualistic I don't think it's a
surprise of both on left and right the
dominant
uh ideologies post World War II have
been away from the communitarian and
towards the individualistic
well and and on that we're all getting a
bit heavy isn't it no I'm liking it I
like it yeah you're saying it very well
I'm learning a lot
um I I mean on the individualistic stuff
I mean it's also let's keep it heavy for
a while it's also about relativism isn't
it
and Charlie uh and I I think I think it
was uh Richard hogger who who first
I first read actually noticed this
tendency in in British life and Western
life
towards a kind of vapid and vacant moral
relativism
and which you hear these days uh
from skanks and more artists when they
say things like don't judge me that
don't don't judge me
well I will judge you you skank I will
judge you
and you cannot stop me doing so but no
you're right it's it's a moral
relativism
um but I mean more crucial than anything
what wokery is and is something which
cannot be challenged
because it's all based upon personal
experience it's my lived experience
that's that's my lift experience uh and
well now this is my Truth uh so so it's
something which you cannot challenge
rationally or empirically and it it it's
very clear about that I mean you know uh
it was the uh one of the boards which
advises Britain's University said it
wished to get University teaching away
from from
european-based rational discourse I mean
they're very very clear that it's not
rational and of course when you when you
look at all the different strands that
intersectional all those all the strands
of wokism
um many of them contradict each other
you know it's it's hilarious well one
thing I did want to challenge you on
slightly uh is that you say it's a
Christian well I've got to challenge you
you're going to get offended
uh you say that worker is a creature of
affluence uh because nobody in Somalia
or Chad gets terribly worked up if you
misgender them I wanted to ask abroad
have you ever tried to misgender anyone
in Somalia or Chad because I have a
sneaking feeling that they might be
quite offended I don't think they would
be at all uh what what I mean I mean
that was a that was a
um a way of capturing the fact that
there is no wokism in those countries
and there isn't it
so don't sit there pretending there is
Frederick okay don't try and pretend to
me that in South Sudan they're terribly
worried about trans quotas for the next
person to you know become Village Elder
and chop off someone's head they are
they are not bothered about that I think
if you kept calling the village Elder a
woman he might get quite cross if you
get but anyway I'm being uh facetious so
you're being impish yeah impish how dare
I
um let's go to on to religion because
that's an important part of your peace
and your thesis uh which is that um
wokery is a sort of it has filled the
void of religion if you like well except
it hasn't I mean it hasn't really filled
the void because it because the thing
which religion gave us was
some easily uh understandable perhaps
simplistic uh Commandments by which we
ought to live our lives as well as stuff
like you know uh the Notions of deferred
gratification the benefits of of working
hard the benefits of saving money and
and of uh and of doing good in this life
uh the religion game is all of that and
we've retreated from religion religion
you know we're now effectively a secular
country I don't think wokism has filled
the void I don't think anything has felt
divided you know I spoke to Charles
Murray the the sociologist the American
sociologist a while ago
uh and he told me uh at the end of our
conversation he said I'm very interested
in Europe you know this is a continent
which has abolished God and it would be
interesting to see what what they put in
its place and the answer is nothing you
know uh nothing at all
um so I I think we've
I think the retreat of religion or the
retreat of us from religion has been one
of the things which has fed into the
rise of wokery
um
almost infinite number of other things
which have fell into it my father used
to say that we have uh externalized uh
well traditionally we used to
externalize religion and internalize
morality and nowadays we do the opposite
is it because we've been doing that for
decades now that we have wokery
um were the courses as I say I think the
causes of white career are many many
fold and and you know touch on such
things as the reform of the divorce laws
the movement of women into the labor
market uh the way in which we teach
children in schools the growth of human
resources for of Human Resources the HR
departments the grosser the growth of
health and safety legislation all these
things have fed into it uh my point is
that we've kind of
is that we've kind of uh built rokery
ourselves and now the recipients of it
so we've
um we only have ourselves to blame
um in terms of you're suggesting that
these days we
um externalize morality yes so we we put
it on other people but not ourselves
yeah I think I think there's there's
some truth in that there's some truth in
that
um but what we've also done is
the the great Mantra of the last 40
years is to remove stigma
so we we try to remove stigma from
people who have mental illnesses we
remove stigma from single mothers we
remove stigma these days from uh the
morbidly obese and the problem is that
stigma is is you know a useful societal
tool for preventing antisocial Behavior
Uh and if you remove stigma as we have
seen the numbers of people who are
morbidly obese or or are single mothers
will grow exponentially and they have I
mean actually in the case of single
mothers exponentially in its proper term
um so so we cannot bear this is part of
the moral relativism stuff which is you
cannot bear to judge other people on
their Lifestyles because we're all
individuals and Society doesn't really
matter it's the such a mantra in a way
so no one can be judged and we can't say
to them you're doing wrong you're doing
something which will deeply harm
yourself harm your children and harm
Society where we're not allowed to say
that anymore
well if if it is inadequate as a
replacement religion do you think it
will collapse quite quickly uh and that
something else uh possibly is long will
spring up in its place
well Islam's Islam
um
Islam has
continued to exist as a consequence of
its refusal to change with uh
shifting morals
um and in a way that the Church of
England has tried to survive
and is not doing so at the moment by
accommodating
um new social morals so yeah I think
there is and not necessarily Islam but
but certainly if you look at the
religious religions which are growing in
in this country it tends to be the
the
somewhat robust side of protestantism uh
you know they're the pentecostalists uh
pentecostalists are thriving
uh you know and growing growing by the
growing by the months uh whereas the the
Lily liver Church of England is is in
kind of terminal decline as is sadly for
me
um uh a church which once
did know about morality and that's a
Methodist Church but it's also become
very very Lefty and woke
one uh thing you put you've got a list
of things which you've mentioned
slightly there about uh things that have
sort of contributed towards the rise of
work the diminution of marriage under
the reform of the divorce laws uh the
lack of an external threat to this
country I was very interested by that no
well yeah that's that's I mean if you
know your sociology right back to
durkheim uh one of the first major
sociological studies Emerald durkheim
study of suicide
uh which tends not to happen when
countries are at War
people tend not to kill themselves uh
there is a sense the the point get
killed somewhere else
yeah absolutely
um but but the point is that we'd emerge
1945 from a war in which we in which the
overriding message was one of
communitarianism that we're all in this
together uh that we all fight together
that we do our duty uh and that we're
doing that we're fighting for something
rather Noble and
um what you tended to get uh is is much
less mental health uh um many much fewer
mental health problems amongst the
population fewer suicides a greater
sense of togetherness a great sense of
pulling together
um whereas the generation which follows
that which is both the Puma generation
and indeed the generations uh Generation
X and Generation Z and the Millennials
haven't had that I mean to a degree the
Boomers have a kind of existential
threat hanging over their heads in terms
of nuclear warfare
which produced a slightly different
response to actually being bombed the
fear of being bombed is is different to
actually being bombed I think
um but but no I I think
um because we've been safe I'm not
suggesting that we should have a good
War Freddy or anything like that that
would do it I'm just saying any more
than I'm saying that you know we
shouldn't have had women into the work
workplace uh but I mean that will be an
absurdity to say that what I'm saying is
that these things have in their own way
contributed towards a more
individualistic Society an awoken
Society
do you think it might explain why we're
perhaps lusting after a threat which
might explain some of the pandemic
response uh possibly the sort of almost
uh bizarre wish that Putin was posing a
nuclear threatenation nuclear threat
well I I think I think there's a few
things we're probably not associated
with vocalism going on with with Russia
uh partly I think it's a sense of
comfort
amongst the military establishment and
to a degree the politicians that we're
fighting an enemy we understand
uh once again whereas you know previous
to that our biggest threats seemed to
come from uh radical Islam and we didn't
have a clue about how to deal with that
um so I think there's a degree of
comfort there
um and and also a slight smugness that
actually the Russians aren't very good
uh
despite despite their history
um so I think that's a I think there's
also something
um which which kind of touches on what
you were saying the slavo uh often often
says and said about smoking actually
which is that
we we have outlawed racism and sexism
and uh homophobia and islamophobia but
we still need someone to hate uh and and
uh slavov suggested that smokers were
one of them and I think he's right I
think you know that's an easy thing to
hate but I think for wokery some of it
is down to a middle class which isn't
allowed to hate anything else and since
it's rather bad to hate things at least
I can hate the lower classes with their
awful awful views about things as such
as transgenderism and immigration
rod that's been a very jolly section uh
appropriate to Christmas uh Happy
Christmas Freddie happy Christmas thank
you for putting on tinsel
all obvious could have wanted thanks
again rod
thank you
foreign
[Music]